it's your turn today I'm going to share
with you three ways that teenagers can
make their dreams come true so I've got
a great question for one of my youtube
viewers love you guys Paul who wrote in
to say your videos are amazing thanks
Paul I appreciate that I really want to
become a man like you in the future i'm
currently in high school but i'm looking
forward to everything you do can you
give me a short summary about how your
business started and how did you become
so successful when you were a teenager
did you have the dream of becoming the
most successful entrepreneur can you
give me some advice as a teen to how to
start your business and take the first
step I'm always thinking but I don't
know how to do it best of luck in the
future i will see you Paul Paul this is
an amazing question and one that I you
know being a father I think more and
more and more about about how I would
like to raise my child and the future of
our of our nation's I didn't grow up
with an entrepreneurial background I
didn't grow up wishing I would be an
entrepreneur because nobody in my family
was an entrepreneur so it didn't have
those role models to look to in high
school in my yearbook I said I wanted to
be a VP at a bank you know where they
ask you what are you going to be in 20
years I said I'd be a VP at a bank so
entrepreneurship wasn't even on my radar
when I went to university I met up with
two people who had started the business
and needed some help on the business
side and I joined them and I had a lot
of fun that was my first real exposure
to entrepreneurship and I ended up
turning down big jobs high paying jobs
jobs that a couple years ago I would
have dreamed of having to do this thing
where we started my own business and at
the time making very little money one of
the hardest decisions I had to make was
deciding between staying at my business
where i was making three hundred dollars
a month and barely surviving and eating
beans for lunch every day and you know
sucking but still feeling full of energy
and wanted to make this thing happen
that versus taking these jobs that these
big companies who are paying me up to
six figures and having me flying around
the world and i said no to those jobs to
do my own business
was a really hard decision but I told
myself two things 1i didn't want to look
back on my life and wish what would have
happened you know what would happen if I
took you know that my own business ever
taking that job and 2 i'm going to give
myself a year i would try this for one
year and give it my best shot so i can
live life with no regrets and ended up
never having to go back and get that job
I've told my store a number of times in
different ways on the channels you can
go back and look at some of the older
videos but today I wanted to share with
you my three bits of advice for
teenagers to help them live their dreams
number one is try a lot of different
things I find that people are offering a
product of their environment and you do
the things that your parents do when
your friends do and your family does and
that may not be the best thing for you
you don't want to limit yourself to only
studying one thing you're only going
into one kind of job because that's what
your parents did now is the time to take
risks to try different things to explore
yourself to find out who you really are
I was fortunate enough to travel a lot
when I was in my teenage years and found
that every time I I saw the world and
came back I was a different person I
learned a lot more about myself and who
I was but also discovered that the world
is so much more than my typical bubble
that i was living in with my friends and
my family so there's something that
interests you something that you want to
do stop just dreaming about its up just
thinking about it go out and try it try
it on a small scale try it on a low-risk
way try it out without spending a lot of
money just try it get out of the I
should do this I want to do this and
start doing number two is do what you
love there is no reason why in this day
and age you should be doing work that
you don't love this is not your parents
world anymore you don't have to do work
that you don't love if you look at any
of the top people in any field in any
business the people at the top are the
ones who love what they do and if you
want to have success if you want to be
happy if you want to feel enriched if
you want to have a positive impact on
the world it's only going to come if you
are doing something that you love and
are passionate about so number one is
you have to try a lot of stuff to find
what you love and then when you
you find what you love you need to run
with it and not listen to any naysayers
a number three is create your own world
we have never had so many opportunities
for young people in the history of the
world you can literally create whatever
you have in your mind and make it a
reality you can turn your dream into a
reality it has never been easier the
challenge for a lot of young people is
believing that because you grow up in a
world where you have older people often
telling you that things can't be done
that way they don't understand how you
can become a multi-millionaire video
game player they don't understand how
you can become a multi-millionaire
full-time youtuber your parents your
school guidance counselor and a lot of
the people who may be telling you that
your dreams are not possible they live
in a different world they're living in a
past world where these things never were
possible before and they're stuck in
their ways of this is the way that
something should be done because they've
been doing it for the past 30 40 50 60
years so if you have your mind set on
doing something have the courage to
follow your heart even when the people
around you are telling you that's not
possible and instead of listening to
them start to surround yourself with
people things ideas and a routine that
build you up and make you believe in
your idea because I'd hate seeing a
young person with dreams and ambition be
squashed down by somebody who never had
any big dreams or ambition and I only
hope that as a father of a child who's
now almost six years old I'll still
remember those lessons in mind when I'm
giving him advice on what he can and
can't do as he grows up believe those of
you guys watching I love to hear what
you have to think leave a comment below
and if you liked this video you want to
see more subscribe to the channel thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
soon self-improvement books are like
fitness books they never work on their
own what you need is a trainer that's
Evan get the newsletter
you